what to bring you the latest from Italy
this is the Italian Prime Minister Conti
speaking we are just hearing that Prime
Minister Conti saying that there will no
longer be this red zone in the north of
the country all of Italy is now going to
be under the same condition all of Italy
now in effect quarantined Prime Minister
Conti saying people should not move
other than for work and emergencies that
means the whole country is affecting in
lockdown he says all public gatherings
will be banned now not be very clear
there what he defines by a public
gathering whether that includes
restaurants and shops and things like
that
no numbers on that yet but will monitor
very closely what the Prime Minister is
saying there he says Prime Minister God
is also saying the right behavior for
the people now is to stay at home and
this is covering the whole of Italy the
whole of Italy now now declared a red
zone people being advised to stay at
home all public gatherings banned and
this after this comes on the day that
Italy reported an increase in
coronavirus cases of over 1700 so even
more draconian measures introduced there
announced there by Italy's Prime
Minister and doing it live as you can
see there in a press conference after
yesterday's extension of the quarantine
zone in the north leaked early and many
people are thought to have been able to
get out of those quarantine zones well
there there if they stayed in Italy
they're not out of them now the whole of
the country declared a red zone more on
that as we hear from Italy's Prime
Minister